hey youtubers is Charlie so yesterday
and my arrow and flash videos I asked
you to submit all of your questions so I
picked 10 of them to answer in this
video with one bonus question also since
then we've got an extended flash trailer
so I'm gonna do a breakdown of the new
things we saw on that if you're finding
me for the first time I'm gonna be doing
arrow and flash bonus videos and the
offseason fight both on Wednesdays be
sure to subscribe to get everything and
leave me suggestions for the stuff you
guys want to talk about first so let's
pick apart some of that flash footage
most of the stuff we saw we already knew
about the costume being from STAR Labs
his inner circle of Caitlin snow and
Cisco Tom Cavanagh though it looks like
he's gonna be their version of publicity
the tech person which I think it's kind
of funny given Felicity's relationship
with the other members of team arrow I
totally loved the way that STAR Labs
looks it looks like it's gonna be their
version of the arrow cave at least in
season 1 the big news though is whether
wizard he's gonna be the first villain
in the first rogue on the show it seems
like they're combining aspects of the
new 52 versions of the characters in the
classic flash stories in the classic
stories the roads aren't metahumans they
just have technology that gives them
their powers in the new 52 comics they
all get exposed to special STAR Labs
tech that gives them real powers so it
seems like all or at least some of the
villains on the show are gonna be
full-on metahumans it's all based on
that particle accelerator explosion
causing weird dark energy to spill into
their dimension I totally love the way
weather Wizards powers looked on the
show I love the way they're doing the
special effects zoom as a villain was
confirmed it's pretty clear he was the
one that killed Barry's mother and we
can unpack all that in the comments for
people who don't know about that story
from the comics because they're directly
adapting some flash origin stories so
the flash is premiering in October no
date officially confirmed but at the
same time as arrow season 3 it'll
probably be around the time arrow season
2 premiered but flash will be on
Tuesdays at 8 p.m. and arrow will stay
on Wednesdays at 8 p.m. - so it's gonna
make it way easier for me to do videos
for both of them so I'm really happy
about that also really important it was
confirmed at the up-front that Malcolm
Merlyn John Barrowman course would be a
cast regular meaning he'd be in most of
the episodes not necessarily as the main
villain but as a regular antagonist so
he's probably going to be causing some
trouble for Team arrow hopefully with
Thea so time to answer some questions
careful for spoilers from the arrow
finale if you haven't seen it yet but
question number one
we asks on facebook andrew kriesberg
said that one of the main cast members
would not be starting season 3 who do
you think it is so it's probably Paul
Blackthorne detective Lance he was at
the CW up front which means that he's
still part of season 3 you know he's not
dying or anything he sustained internal
injuries during that police station
fight so he might go into a coma or just
sit out a few episodes on medical leave
but he's definitely coming back he's not
off the show like he's not leaving
question number two Neil's asks could
Edward fryers from season one on the
island have been hired by Amanda Waller
yes it's totally possible but they'd
have to mess with some of the history on
the show that the mess with the cannon
Edward fryers was gonna use the weapons
to disable eyes the Chinese honk-honk
situation the lady in red shoes in that
scenario did not look like Amanda Waller
she wasn't black
but Amanda Waller was operating in Hong
Kong around that time the cast heard
during season two's so it's possible
that they could wreak on that woman in
red shoes to be Amanda Waller remember
they did the same thing with Katie Lots
in those scenes on the island whenever
the boat crashed the other possibility
is is that it's someone from hive and
it's someone new will meet I know a lot
of people also thought that woman in red
from season one might be Isabel rochev
but I don't think that she would have
been powerful enough five years ago to
poff an operation of that size question
number three did you destined asks what
was happening in that scene after Oliver
left the island
so the Amazo boat blows up and Oliver
wakes up in Hong Kong presumably being
drummed into service with Argus and
Amanda Waller it looks like he worked
with her and then ended up back on the
island at some point in the pilot
episode he seemed pretty cool and
level-headed
but that mega beard makes me think that
he had been stranded there for a while
so clearly he probably went on missions
for Argus and then at some point one of
them went really bad and he got stranded
on the island again the interesting
thing is that the show always goes back
to the island because it's purgatory
it's this metaphor for Oliver's life as
well as his hero's journey for any
joseph campbell geeks out there it's
like his transitory state between
justice league and his old life so until
he either one dies or two makes it to
that Justice League moment the show is
always gonna keep going back there so
there will be Island scenes in season 3
question number 4
McLovin asks will team arrow and team
flash ever combined forces to fight a
single villain yes they totally cannot
have their
Avengers schwarmann oment until they
fight some sort of common enemy Oliver
isn't just gonna drop in and say hi on
the flash though whenever they go on
each other's shows it will be because
there's a problem in Central City that
only Oliver and Felicity can solve and
vice-versa on arrow as for who that
villain might be it all just depends on
which villains the show's bring on in
the new seasons zoom is the big bad on
flash so there's the possibility that
team arrow could help Barry with that or
Felicity could help him with his
mother's murder
you know her skills are very CSI
friendly when everyone goes to Comic Con
this summer and they do their panels
they'll probably talk about a little bit
more than about the crossovers question
number five peacekeeper boy asks who do
you think is going to be the main
villain next season and how many
episodes of the flash will there be so
just talking about the flash the main
villain will always be zoom but there's
always a big villain that works for the
main villain so secretly that might be
Tom Cavanagh scare achter like wolf in
sheep's clothing kind of thing or it
could be one of the Rogues like Captain
Cold my money is on one of the Rogues
just because that'd be way more fun it
could also be all the Rogues coming
together though I think we're gonna see
an origin story for the Rogues because
they're not the Rogues until they become
a team as four episodes they haven't
said officially but the show has at
least eight or nine episodes if they get
picked up for the second half of the
season they'll get the full twenty two
arrow on the other hand usually gets 23
episodes which is a lot most shows only
get 20 or 22 episodes for a full season
so here's a really important thing at
the upfront CW was touting the flash as
the show that they were most proud of
they were positive that it was gonna be
a hit so get really excited for that it
means they're just gonna throw that much
more energy into marketing it and making
it you know the next big new thing that
they have question number six manga
Netta asks which villains do you think
that we'll see on the flash so I think
that they'll just stick to the core
rogues in season one I think there will
be at least one surprise like someone
that arrow shares in common with them
someone we've already heard about on
arrow like hive as for a weather wizard
in the trailer if you're not familiar in
the pre new 52 comics he used a weather
control rod to control the weather like
he was just a regular guy with
technology and in the new 52 comics on
the show he's a metahuman with real
superpowers that enable him to control
weather like he's mostly gonna be
generating tornadoes based on those last
moments in the trailer
it looks like Barry is gonna use you
know the solution to that giant tornado
you know trying to run in the opposite
direction to learn just how fast he can
run the speed force isn't like you know
a stop-and-go thing there are different
levels of speed that the flashers can
achieve it's a lot like Internet
bandwidth if you have internet at your
house it moves slower when a bunch of
people are downloading stuff at once but
when it's just one person downloading
it's way faster so the more flashes that
are in one place accessing the
speedforce at the same time the slower
they can all run because we know zoom is
Edward Thawne and he works with Barry
you've got two flashes drinking from the
fountain in the comics whenever Barry is
the only one accessing the Speed Force
he can run so fast that he can go
forwards and backwards in time so him
trying to run back in time and prevent
his mother's murder might be a thing
Nick season I think it's gonna take him
most of the season to learn about the
Speed Force so don't plan on any time
travel anytime soon it's mostly gonna be
like superheroes CSI question number
seven michelle asks what do you think
Felicity's backstory is gonna be yes
we're supposed to get a whole bunch more
felicity backstory in season three and
I'm really excited I think it'd be
really cool if they tried to invoke some
of the firestorm aspects of her
character from the comics but they might
change things and make her father part
of the mythos like make her father the
professor of Martin Stein part of the
character it's a little far-fetched but
I think it would be totally awesome but
it's also possible that they can make
her father part of hive usually when
people in comic book shows don't like to
talk about their parents a lot it's
because something really awful happened
to them like they were fused with the
firestorm matrix or they did something
really awful a la villains so I'm
calling it right now either her father
is part of a superhero mythos like a
team of some sort or he's one of the
villains he's not gonna be just a
regular guy question number eight meta
de Toro asks do you think that Oliver
knows about Connor no I don't think he
knows I think arrow would be trolling
fans too much if Oliver always knew
everything and then just never told the
rest of team arrow or the fans like when
he had the vial of the cure of this
season he had that cure the whole season
and he waited six months to tell them
that kind of made me mad so I don't
think that he'd turn around and do the
exact same thing but I do think whenever
he does find out about his son he'll
keep his distance remember he gave full
that speech early on in season 2 about
getting too close to the people he loves
you know and keeping them safe by
staying away question number 9 green
quiver asks could Thea become chesh ire
totally I saw a bunch of you commenting
on the last video that she looked a lot
more like a Shire than the Artemis
character you have to remember though
regardless of who is what in the comics
they can always give any minor superhero
persona to any of the characters like
making Felicity the Oracle character you
know originally in the comics that was
Barbara Gordon so even though Artemis in
the comics is the daughter of sports
master Thea could still become her on
the show regardless of who she ends up
becoming I think she's gonna be a little
bit more like the canary whenever she
comes back you know just much more of a
badass question number 10 Jean Loup asks
will hive come back so even if hive is
not the main villain
I think they'll definitely come back
because they tease them pretty hardcore
last season they'll be like an evil
version of Argus so don't be surprised
if Merlin gets mixed up with them
remember he lost his company and all his
money just like Oliver so where did he
get that limo from at the end I mean
he's got to be getting money from
somewhere and one last bonus question
iron guardian asks do you think that the
flash will have flashbacks like arrow or
be more like CSI with mystery solving
side quests so they cast Barry's mother
she's an actual character on the show so
they will have at least some flashbacks
to that moment but in terms of daily
flashbacks I think we'll see more cut
twos like the murder mystery
investigation will be going off in the
background of each episode so think of
it more like an episode of like bones
with superpowers
he'll be using his abilities and STAR
Labs to connect crime scenes to the
particle accelerator explosion and
metahumans that'll be popping up all
over Central City so thank you so much
for submitting your questions these are
always a ton of fun to do and like I
said in the off season I'm gonna be
doing weekly arrow and flash bonus
videos you know separate videos for each
one be sure to subscribe to get
everything and let me know what you guys
want to talk about first also be sure to
let me know if you guys want me to keep
on doing Q as for arrow and flash stuff
but if I do I might just combine them
and do one for both shows so right now
you can click here to get my review the
arrow finale
here to learn about my top five flash
villains we might actually see some of
them on the show this year thanks so
much for watching I'll see you guys
tomorrow
high fives
you